strain my day junkie block my night all
day yeah yeah yeah he's a bad
[ __ ] and I don't know I don't
mean they said he signed the floyd
mayweather deal only way yep he signed
when did that happen it did happen
yesterday he has signed Floyd Mayweather
has not time to negotiating Ashley
Madison yep pure boxing yeah it says I
think my people like I mean maybe he's
going to go full Bernard Hopkins just
[ __ ] clinch and hit him in the clinch
and tie them up and rough him up and
maybe that's the plan lean on his neck
you know just pro fight dirty let him
take points away because a [ __ ] long as
it'll get disqualified don't like stand
in the middle of the ring and try to
[ __ ] shuck and jive with them but the
other thing is Floyd's not knocking a
lot of people out yeah you know it's a
good fight in terms of like to see what
the [ __ ] happens yeah how much money is
that going to make he's going to make a
[ __ ] ton of money he's going to make the
heap estimated I don't know if it's true
between 75 and 100 million dollars all
good at all and then who knows how much
Floyd's going to make somewhere in that
range to maybe more probably more but I
think that it's going to be interested
first of all Floyd's 40 almost 41
Floyd's maybe the best defensive boxers
ever walked the face of the planet
I mean he's right up there and mile when
you go back to Willie Papp a lot of the
guys from the old days and for sure
lomachenko today but in terms of like
overall performance against elite
fighters over the course of his career
the guys only been tagged hard like five
or six times ever he's a [ __ ] freak
and hard work I mean he's a you look at
him he's throwing money around driving
Bentley's but that [ __ ] guy will get
on this trip and he'll be running miles
at 3 o'clock in the morning he opens up
his gym 3 o'clock in the morning just
does 15-round to the back just he works
hard me I don't know if he works that
hard anymore yeah that'll be an
interesting one [ __ ] yeah
I'll watch it I hope because they don't
look he might get it kind of might get
his ass handed to him
but he might not yeah you know he might
tak Boyd I mean if he can
Conor is very good at closing distance
and snapping off like lead shots like
it's one of the things that he did with
Nate and he's a southpaw
if he can just snap off one or two
clean shots and make it interesting
it'll be fun know if you can I don't I
don't know what he can do straight box
it's so hard to judge come on to judge
without without knowing without see and
if they do do it I think they're going
to do it somewhere around September I
think that's the idea
Jesus Christ so what's he doing with UFC
until then nothing nothing
so the lightweight division is on
hostage right now they're being held
hostage
interim something or they were supposed
to do that but [ __ ] Habib
nurmagomedov got sick trying to make the
weight and didn't make the way what
happened there
[Applause]
[Music]